Please welcome Will Smith, Joel Edgerton, Noomi Rapace,
Lucy Fry, and director David Ayer.
(audience cheers)
(mumbled voices)
Yes, yes, yes.
It's clear.
(audience cheers)
Let's do this, my god.
Yeah!
Yeah, woohoo!
Whoa that is, that was too much.
He needs to settle down.
What I did was a little much.
You startled me.
I'm sorry.
You come out, it's so clear that you,
because I've talk to you so many times,
it's so clear when you come out and there's an audience,
you love being Will Smith.
You enjoy it.
I love it.
It's fun, right?
Yeah.
(audience cheers)
It's not right.
I tried being Denzel a couple days, you know?
It's too intense.
It's just yeah, it's just a lot of energy, you know.
All right.
I love my life, man I'm having such a good time.
There are so many people that are curious,
what is this movie about?
In your best, what's your best description,
brief description of what this movie's all about?
It's funny, it's really difficult.
We all read it and we loved it,
and we like yeah, we wanna make it, right?
But I guess the best way that I can describe it,
imagine Training Day, right?
The energy of Training Day, David wrote Training Day.
Yup, yup.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
Training Day.
Energy of Training Day, got it.
So, it's like the energy of Training Day
meets Lord of the Rings.
(audience laughs)
Right?
Got it, got it.
Yeah.
So, imagine Lord of the Rings was 4,000 years ago.
But then the creatures came forward into present day,
and now we're in gritty, grimy present-day Los Angeles.
Right.
But there's orcs and stuff running around.
(audience laughs)
Plus just a smidgen of Home Alone is in there too.
Yeah, yeah, right, yeah.
(laughs)
Now I'm curious, I'm just curious what you're gonna do
because you have this famous tradition of you like
to see a movie in the theater when it opens.
This is on Netflix, what are you gonna do?
How do you do that?
Yeah, that's a little different,
that's a little different 'cause it's been a big thing
when I would have Big Willie weekend
and all of that type of stuff.
I had a Big Willie weekend once.
(audience laughs)
You're gonna have to break into someone's house.
Yeah.
That didn't go well.
That didn't come out right, yeah.
That didn't go well at all.
Yeah.
So, what are you gonna do?
You can't see in the theaters.
Can't see it in the theaters, so it'll be like--
Home visits.
Yeah, you just go to people's house,
you go to people's house.
Would you guys, the whole cast should go to people's homes
and just look in--
Yeah, yeah.
(audience cheers)
Exactly.
People would like that.
So, it'd be like this, imagine you watching the film,
so you're looking forward, you watching the movie.
I'm watching the movie, yeah.
You watching the movie.
Enjoying it, I'm having a good time.
I'm Netflixing and I'm chilled,
and then all of a sudden--
(audience laughs)
(screams)
Hey, you digging it homie?
You digging it homie?
I'm digging it, I'm digging it.
It's really good.
Yeah, good job, good job.
That's gonna be fantastic.